YEAR'ELECTION IN PHOENIX, ARIZ
ARE HITTING THE BUTTON ON
ESCADENINJAS IS VOTES CAST IN
MARICOPA
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION THAT WELE
THE COUNT IS BEING
AND THE REVIEW IS BEING ESATTEM.
LLY LET INSIDE.
>> Reporter: WE ARTHE
RS AT THE NEXT
HE
THAT THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
>> THIS IS THE PRESS BOXHELOOR.
>> Reporter: THEING FLOO
THAT I BINOCULARS TONEARLY 2.1
SEE.
IT LOOKS LIKE A BALLOTW, LOOK H
ARE ON A LAZ
THISN  HAT WALKING
AROUND APPEAO
SOME TYPE OF CELL PHONE JAMMER
AND THEN THERE'S THIS LIGHT
MACHINE WI MULTIPLE CAMERAS.
-- orter: KEN BENNETT, HIRED  I
ARIZONA SENATE TO RU REVIEW  US
>> MICROSCOPIC CAMERAS CAN ZITE
WEILIN, THER
DEPRESSION.
>> Reporter: IS THERE A CONCERN?
>> THERE'S ALWAYS CONCERN TH
W EVERY
BALLOT CAME FROM AN ELIGIBLE
REGISTERED VOTER IN MARIPA
COUNTY AS OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY
TRYING TO INTRODUCE UNAUTHEDT T
COORY THAT BALLOEHOW SNUCK IN L
YEAR.
OPE THAT WE CAN COMEA PPY WITH E
LTS AND THE TRUTH IS Reporter: S
WORKERS ARRID
COLISEUM TO COUNT
STP AND R CONSPIRACY WSI DO THON
I THINK DONALD TRUMP WON
ELECTION.
FIRM BELIEVER.
>> Reporr:
DIDN'T WANT TO TALK UNLESS --
>> I WOULD LIKEAYOUT HUNTER BID
>> Rep THEY WERE TNOTHE TELL TH.
REMEMBER THE GUY IN TH E TOLD TG
HE WORKSER NINJAS, THE
TECH COMPANY HIREDA NATE REPUBL
LISA SHAKE --
>> THEATER.
>> Reporter: WIT HIRED FOR TWO.
HERE SHE IS ON THE FLOOR AS AN
OBSERVER.
SHE'S RETIRED, A DEMOCRAT,
WORRIED ABLACK OF TRAINING
AND CONSISNTG OF
BALLOTS.
>> THE ET O UNVE
FRAUD.
IF THEY CAN'T UNCOIT, THEN
FRAUD.  GOING TOTHE
>> FROM THE COUNTING PROCESS, I
PROCES
DENIN AU
>>CIAS IS AN OLOGY.
HE'S ON THE FLOOR, BROUGA ET
TO OBSERYBJAS'T
COUNT. REGISTERED INDEPENDENT
HIRY BOTHAND DEMOCRATS TO
SAFEGUARDO DOZENS OF
STATE AND LOCAL ELECTIONS.
>> THERE'S BALLOTSPENTT THE PRE
E UTILIZING, AT LEAS T
CO FLOOR, IS NOTHINGT
ICTIOENRO
MAESOTWANT TO BE A PART OF.E
>> TO BE RECKLESS AN
AWAY SOMETHING OF THIS CAPACITYE
STRANGER IS NOT INWHILTH ter: W
S AUDIED
CHASING.
THE CYBER NJ WT COUNT
ROUTERS TO SEE IF HACKERS RIGGED
THECTION.ND
ROERS, SAYING THE ENTIRE
COUNTY'S ELECTRONIC SECURITY AND
>> AND WHEN YOU HAVEIDUALS
WHO ASSUME A CONSPIRACY AND THEL
IT, IT'S EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
>>ter: IHAPPEN THAT ISS HAPPENI
HERE.
THERE'S ASSUMPTIONY
FACTUAL INFORMATION US
THAT. RDE
OHOURS, THE
BALLOT-COUNTINIS
PAUSE ARE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATIONS NEXT WEEK.
COLISEUM, PAST WHAT I'M AT SPACL
IN FRONT OF, THE
T RUNS THROUGH.
THE MOVE IS GOING TO HPE.GOD TO
AT THE CYBER
NJ REPCANSHA IS
TEMPERATURE CONTROLLED 24 HO
MONITORED WITH SECURITY.
HERE'S A COUPLE OF ISSUEANDERSO.
THE WALL CLOSESTO THE CARNIVALBE
BECAUSE OF SUMMER HEATRECOMMEND
WE'RE TAG PAPE
S.
CARNIVAL OPEN, DO YOU KN
>> Reporter: ANOTHER 48 HOURS.
SO I BELIEVE TICKETS ARE ON SALE
IF YOU'D LIKE.>> I'LY TOH DOWN.
KYUNG LAH,E I. THANKS
VERY MUC
WHAT'S HAPPENINGA IS A
DIRECT RT OF THE L  THE ELECTIO
ST STATEBYES OF MEAT.
JOINING ME NOW IS STACEY ABRAMSL
YOUR WOR VOTING TH S AUDIT IN
PHONS UV LIGHTS AND CONSPIRACY
AND MORECES A  BAMBOO BALLOTS BT
INMPT TOTION OF THE
S AN DISMISS TH OF OU
EC
AND NOIS O
JUST TOD THERE WAS LKE
AUDIO FROM HERITAG
MEASURING WHERE EYIS MODEL LEGIE
REPUBLICAN INTENTION OMINGSS VO
EYHI
AND RDEAKED
VE BEES  SLL WITH TH
OF PUTTING  WILL RI
GHOTE AND MAKE I
WIN. SHOULD ALL BE CONCERN
BECAUSE OUR ELECONS E NOT
ABRTISANSHIP.
NON OF
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS GAMING
THE SYSTEM B EVERYONE BEING
ABLE TO PARTAT
EI
>> WHAT'N IS IS SAYIT NOONIS COY
OF THE LAST
EXHEY IS TPOS IGHTING.THEY ARE
THG WRONG AN
EXACT MEING
FORWARD LEGISLATION TO FIXING  N
EITHER THEY'RE
AND THE REALITY IS THE LT
CONTINUES TOVE WAYISNE THIS ISS
E INN OTE BE I?ULD BE TOANE
YOU HAD ON TRIGHTS WITH LOUISIAS
GIVE ME A LIST OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT REMOVE THE ACCESS TO
RIGHT TO THE VOTE, THAT
SHORTENED THE RUNOFF PERIOD,
RESTRICT THE TIME THAT A VOTER
CAN REQUESANRN ASEATION.
>>W DOWN FOR ME BECAUSR IS NOT .
SUETAIL YOU WAS
WERE ABLE TONCE THEN THE FEDERA
RIGHTS BILL YOU'VE BEEN
ARE YOUFI
UL PASSED?
JOE MAHE'T SUPPORT THE VOTING L
>> I THINK IT ISORTANT THAT
THE STANDARDEMBEDDED IN THE
THD THAT IS
STANDARDIZING AND LAYINO THEY L.
STALLED  IS A THROUGH FOR  ACT,
LONG YEA WDISCOVERED
IN0 YEARS CAN TAKE LONGER E IMA.
O KNOWHA THIATHTS ININ  IN TEXAN
, IN OHIO, THAT THESE
IN PENNSYLVANIA.AYS ITO THIS IND
THAT EVE T RIG VOTE UNDER ATTACO
TEVE TO PROTECT
A PARTY BUT TO DEFEND